it is in a way a tech no no our right
because it's this crime story with all
these twists and turns all these
unreliable narrators in this unusual
setting online
I'm Josh Berman and I wrote a two-part
series about the Silk Road and it's a
story about this illegal clandestine
drug Bazaar well as interesting Ross
Ulbricht who started the site was a
scientist as he got interested in
libertarian economics and wanted to sort
of program this experiment in a sense
Silk Road was a disruption idea because
Ross used tor a protocol that allows you
to basically visit and run a site
anonymously it was sort of like a hidden
Amazon it was really hidden anybody
could use it but the government couldn't
track who was using it or find it so you
could buy heroin or cocaine and you know
all the vendors you could see like the
transaction ratings like it actually is
a very efficient system over very well
and I was very sympathetic to Ross when
I was writing and thinking about what he
started you know the like promise of
youth and a big idea like I could you
could see it being very exciting you
know it sort of curdled into something
else and and also became about ego if it
wasn't for the murder stuff I think a
lot of people would be very sympathetic
it sounds great until you try to put the
revolution into into practice and then
all of a sudden you know you're like my
idea is so good I have to kill you right
well this is a kind of a crazy story
report it's not my usual type of thing
I'm going federal criminal investigation
because that's hard right nobody's
supposed to talk to you and there's want
to talk to you it took a long time you
know to establish trust in the way that
I wanted to tell the story which was as
this big narrative about identity and
how moral transformations happen which
you can see over time with all
characters it just had more as a
true-crime story but also this really
human story